what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking up with x-men black and
in juggernaut so what this does is it
initially picks up with him invading the
Xavier Institute and and for the most
part it makes sense because jaggernots
always been an enemy of the x-men and
him invading the Xavier Institute was
really like his first debut into Marvel
Comics and it almost kind of seems like
a throwback because when he does when he
invades the Institute it's the original
x-men and they're all wearing their
original outfits and so right off the
bat it's like okay either this is a
throwback comic like a memory that's
being relived or something's wrong and
and it's kind of cool because because
Robby Thompson kind of toys us a little
bit until he doesn't
until Ken Marcou starts looking around
and saying this isn't right like
something here is wrong there's no
reason this one should be the original
x-men into all of them wearing their
original outfits like you've literally
got Warren Worthington as his original
angel outfit so it's kind of this is a
little off something doesn't seem right
here and his initial thought is that
Xavier is the one that's behind it but
then it suddenly it dawns on Marko he's
wearing his helmet he's basically immune
to telepathy that's one of the big big
points behind his character is the x-men
have to forcefully remove his helmet in
order to get him to go back or to put
him in a position where he succumbs to
telepathy but because he has his helmet
on his thought or he really comes to the
recognition there's no way xavier z'
behind this because xavier cannot
penetrate his helmet and so that's when
he basically ends up seeing this little
childlike version of himself kind of
talked to him a little bit and then of
course juggernaut chases him down and
that's when he starts to realize like
something's off here
his mind's being toyed with his mind's
being messed with and that's when we
jump to the temple of citta rock in
Thailand and so it really looks like
Marvel's kind of shifting that and
moving the location from Korea to
Thailand proper which again is kind of
strange it's kind of interesting they
would do that but shifting its location
only for us to realize he's basically
being manipulated by these forces of
sitter act and so they really make this
comment they like the juggernauts weak
he's weaker than he used to be he's not
as strong and capable as he used to be
which kind of makes sense because over
there's over the course of Marvel Comics
the German has powers have waxed and
waned I mean there's been times where
he's been like you know eighth day
juggernaut or like try on juggernaut
where he's basically like holding one
hundred percent of the power sit Iraq
he's like a hundred feet tall and and
completely and totally unstoppable like
shattering the unit or shattering
reality with his punches and stuff like
that but because his powers have changed
there's never really been a definitive
standard as to how powerful the
juggernaut is standing on his own you go
read the old journey into mystery the
old for comics Thor throws a hammer atom
and it bounces off that's because he has
a shield you read some of the x-men
stories you x-men defeat him
by removing his helmet you read stories
where he fights the Incredible Hulk and
into the Incredible Hulk overpowers him
or the Incredible Hulk moves him using
his momentum I mean that's one of the
big things there like you read the old
Peter David run Warhawk stops him in his
tracks but then you read you read the
the story of world war hulk and The
Incredible Hulk just diverts his
momentum so it changes like it just kind
of fluctuates over the years by and
large the eighth day juggernaut
storyline and the Trion juggernaut
storyline and the old uncanny x-men
stories those are largely considered to
be the most powerful versions of his
character but in terms of him on an
average day it really kind of fluctuates
depending on who's writing the story and
so where he faces off against the x-men
is really kind of facing off against
them and kind of his mind at the same
time and as he begins to succumb to his
anger and as he begins to succumb to his
rage that's when he kind of taps into
his actual power and then CID Iraq
emerges and we end up finding out the
city rock has been manipulating this the
entire time as a means to test Cain
Marko and that's why it's kind of cool
because sin Iraq is the one that gave
kmart are really allowed que Marco to
access his full power remember when it
comes to the Crimson Jim is the
inscription that basically reflects
whatever language the reader speaks and
it says whosoever touches this stone
shall be a yachtie become a human
juggernaut and so it's kind of cool here
because city rock is like this super
powerful entities basically a god now
the idea of city rock is to always try
to find a way to escape the Crimson
dimension and he really feeds on like on
rage and destruction that's one of the
reasons why having his avatar in the
form of juggernaut was so cool because
juggernaut was basically like a mindless
beast you know Keene Walker would say
well I'm not stupid and that's true I
mean you know relative to a tree stump
came Markos pretty smart but relative to
someone like like an average person of
above-average intellect he's kind of
dumb and so he would basically just like
go through and tear things up because
that's what Kane Marco does and he was
the perfect avatar for that purpose and
so worse interact starts you know
taunting him and starts giving him a
hard time we end up finding out that
what sitter axe doing is testing him sit
Iraqis basically come to the conclusion
that he's been watching Cain Marko for
some time and he came to the realization
that hey Marko has been holding back
that all this time that that cane has
been the juggernaut outside of the 8th
day story outside of the Trion story
he's been holding back his full power
for whatever reason because he's scared
because he doesn't really want to hurt
people
whatever the case says he's always been
holding things back and the response of
sinirage is to say let all that rage
loose you've got
unbridled untapped rage let it all out
like let every ounce every ounce of it
loose and when he does he absolutely
thrashes sit erect now to give you guys
perspective this is huge I mean this is
massive it's it's it's it's absolutely
insane if you like if the Incredible
Hulk like fought and defeated Dormammu
which I guess is possible after a
certain amount of time but in his own
dimension sin Iraq is insanely powerful
no in reality ifs in Iraq chose to he
could just phase you know juggernaut out
of existence but when it comes to like
raw brutal strength it's one of these
things where the juggernaut almost
appears to be equal to sin Iraq in terms
of just like raw power and rage and
indestructibility and that's what Sid
Iraq was going for it was basically
unlocking the full rage of the
juggernaut but basically this means that
like hey Marco is more powerful than
he's ever been that he's achieved a
level of like rage that sin Iraq can
continue to feed on but hey Marco
himself can implement now how this is
used I don't really know because when it
comes to raw physical strength very few
people can actually best Cain Marko in
hand-to-hand combat even before this you
know again it took the Incredible Hulk
as the horseman of war imbued with like
celestial technology drawing on the
power of another universe in order to
stop Cain Marko in his tracks I saw
Lucius kind of like damn now he's more
powerful than that and so maybe that's
the case maybe it's one of these things
where Marvel's twin with the idea and
saying he's basically eighth day
juggernaut now and and we don't know
that for absolute certainty I don't see
guys who don't know the eighth day
juggernaut event was a story where where
it goes back into the nature of the
Octus right like in the early days of
Earth there were these demons that
existed on earth itself when all hell
broke loose among the Elder Gods they
just they flee they base it all just
took off for their lives they ended up
taking up residence well in different
dimensions and then from there they had
like this wager right like like
whoever's like late there were two these
different artifacts who would put him
around the world and whoever discovered
the first one that would lead to the
initiation of the whole campaign and
that would basically lead to like people
being drawn to it the first one to grab
it would be the avatar of that
particular deity in this case Cain Marko
was the avatar of sin Iraq each one
would create an army using one-eighth of
the human population they would fight
each other in whichever population
basically one destroyed all the others
that would prove which member of the
outcasts was the most powerful and then
juggernaut basically like received like
or at least it wasn't really the full
force of
of sin Iraq ah but like a huge portion
of it and was insanely powerful I know
he's absolutely bonkers how powerful he
was but again because the juggernaut
uses super strength it's one of those
things where it's like how strong he is
and how durable he is at any point in
time it's relative to the person he's
fighting and so because like even you
know even beyond that the strength of
various individuals like Thor and The
Incredible Hulk and like gladiator and
Hyperion because their strength varies
depending on who we're talking about
like gladiator for example his power is
relative to his confidence in himself so
when you when you have those things that
kind of come together it's very
difficult to like pin down how strong
juggernaut is when he's that like his
baseline form he's really strong and
durable and that's that's really all you
can say this kind of seems to be
building on that and saying well however
strong and durable he was before
he's now stronger and more durable than
that what that means that's anybody's
guess you'd have to see him fight the
Incredible Hulk to really find out but
yeah I'm kind of hoping that we get that
you know like the juggernauts real power
like the dogger not actual power
released or something like that I mean I
don't know it cuz he's he's limited by
how powerful he or how much rage he has
so I don't know if he's like 100 percent
as powerful as you could be it's one of
those weird things but any of it let me
know you guys think down in the comments
section we have being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]